The increasing temperature will change, so
you have to tell this. Clear others. Okay, you have to
tell which of these changes with temperature. This is
just a matter and
not once but a thousand times this question has come and
how many people already knew.  How many people
today came to know that this one is ok, that's why
you must have seen that after making A out of 100, you must have got lots of formulas for
conversion, but I
believe in you, the more you make it from the basics,
the better your science will be. Everyone is A C, it
means B A.  B C, all three answers have come,
no problem, there is no harm in making a mistake,
you go to the previous screen, it means it is asking you
who is volume dependent, who is volume
dependent, go and see which one has
volume, then children, there will be mole
fraction here, no, there will be no weight.  There will be
molality otherwise what will be the answer C
molality